Matt we are here here it's all happening
its long-awaited that was Matt James in
March speaking exclusively with et as
filming was about to begin for Claire
Crawley season of The Bachelorette
it was then put on hold because of
coronavirus concerns then on Friday
things got changed up in an epic way
Matt was announced as The Bachelor
making him the first black male lead in
franchise history the new bachelor Matt
James joins us now Matt congratulations
and you really know how to keep a secret
so clears journey will still happen but
Matt will no longer be a part of it
instead he'll mark the milestone as the
25th bachelor after claire season did
you want to go on the show for a while
you know I didn't think I was gonna be
on the show and then Tyler's mom
actually recommended that I go on and
she nominated me I just actually got
back from her funeral so she'd be happy
to know that that I followed through
with it man he's got real emotional real
fast that's pretty amazing that's such a
story how does that feel for you what
was she the one who nominated you or she
just encouraged you to do it and and how
does it feel being here now and
following through on that so she had
nominated me and I think she saw
everything that it did for Tyler and the
way that he had changes a man and me
being his roommate and being one of her
sons I think that she wanted something
like that for myself so I wanted to see
it boo for her and just to see what I
would be compatible with Claire so what
why did she see you as being right for
all this you said you changed Tyler as a
man tell me about that a little bit I
think the experience changed Tyler as a
man and just he came back different just
more in touch with who he was as a
person and what he wanted in a
relationship and I feel like I'm ready
for something like that this has to be
wild for you because you're about to
embark on something that is a really
wild ride and you're coming off of a
really really crazy time where are you
kind of at mentally right now I think
I'm grounded you know I a lot of things
that I've done leading up to this point
just making sure that I'm having
constant conversations with my mom
people that I'm not gonna be around for
a while
and that I love him respect to just kind
of put me in the right mindset to make
sure I'm doing everything that would
make them proud so I think me and CeeCee
are cut from the similar cloth just with
our moms being super impact
our lives and if it ever came to someone
disrespecting a woman that we were
pursuing or a woman that was around us
and I think I'd hope that I'd step up
and take a stand for her so are you
worried about anything because Tyler
went through some heartbreak and this
show is a wild ride how are you feeling
you know I feel like like I was telling
you these past few months I've just had
a lot of conversations with the people
that I respect my mom Tyler close
friends and people who have gone through
similar situations in terms of being in
their long relationship and being having
a heartbreak and just staying grounded
like I said and being myself and
hopefully she'll love that and we'll get
to know each other a lot better I gotta
ask you I was a little surprised to hear
about your casting because look you and
Tyler good-looking guys you're fit guys
you're living in New York living this
life where I'm sure a lot of Tyler fans
were around what you want to walk away
from that you were living your best life
in NYC I think a lot of times when
you're in a city like New York or just
any big-time metropolitan you have a lot
of distractions so for me it's work it's
the work we do with the kids at ABC Food
Tours its fitness a lot of I've seen
I've seen the Instagram stories you
you're having some great parties I'm
honestly asking you why do you want to
walk away from like an awesome partying
life in New York City is a guy in his
20s and then go on this show are you
really ready to get married so a lot of
that that you see in that goes on is
theirs it's really fruitless there's not
a lot of meaning in that stuff and I'm
looking for something meaningful and I
think like you get a you're super
clouded with what's going on in the city
and outside distractions and when you
take yourself outside those situations
and you can really focus on somebody
especially someone like Claire who's had
a lot of life experience and someone who
knows what she wants that's really what
I'm excited about anything that you're
afraid of in all this you know you're
afraid to get your heart broken we've
all been there and when you're
vulnerable when you put yourself out
there like that
you've got to be ready for that to
happen so we'll see how it goes
I'm so glad we've met I don't know I I
hope things work out with you and Claire
but if not Matt for bachelor now I hope
it works out her twos I hope we won't
have to get to that point
what would you say no to it well hope we
won't get there I'll hopefully I'll be
with Claire so
but I mean you right now you just sold
me on it okay but good luck with Claire
we're happy to see you